I think we've finally done it
we've finally bitten off more than we can chew
so welcome to side quest No. 798
where we attempt to renovate a 50 year old pool
with no pool renovation experience
and instead, should I be focusing on my
creepy laundry makeover?
probably but am I also very easily distracted
by shining new side quests
you already know the answer to that
and as you can see this pool
for lack of a better phrase
is fkd
It’s filthy
for starters we've got tiles coming off
paint coming off holes in the plaster and
an algae infestation
but like everything else that we found in this house
she's got fantastic bones
she just needs a little.. shaping 💅
and this is a sentence I don't say often
it's enormous
it's about 10 metres long
five metres across and well over two metres in the deep end
and she's made of concrete so she's a sturdy girl
We had a great summer here last year
but we decided that by the time summer rolled around again
we were gonna have done some work on the pool
and summer's coming so we better get to
first step was to drain it
and Goldie was deeply curious about the circles on the bottom
which are left over from previous repairs
and I just wanna let you know that
we haven't gone into this project completely blind
We had multiple pool people come over and give us their thoughts
we've had experts come and check
out all of our pipes and pumps
and make sure that they're all good
And prior to starting the aesthetic work
we did have one pump in the spa replaced
but that was only because
one of the kids thought it would be a good
idea to post a sinkie into
so the boys and by boys I mean
my husband and my eldest son
made a start by chipping off all of the existing waterline tiles
and these are obviously a gorgeous vintage tile
we did actually go down the route of exploring
whether or not we could salvage them
and we hunted and hunted but we couldn't find a match
and the reality is they're really just hanging on by a thread at this point
so they did need to go
and I have got an idea in mind about how I
might be able to upcycle them
so that they can continue to live on here at the pool
but I'll have to keep you posted on that
so anyway you've just seen Mark remove about 16,133 tiles
which I find oddly satisfying
and I don't know what it is about this man
he loves to vacuum
but only on a job site
I don't know if anyone wants to know the history
but I personally find it fascinating
this pool was put in about 20 years after the original home was built
I think around a similar time that they built the extension
and if I have my facts straight
at the same time there were also horses roaming around this property
it was definitely a homestead at one point
but it has been subdivided
if I understand correctly
the mum was an avid swimmer
maybe even competitive?
which explains this massive pool
by the way I'm posting in real time
and there is still so much to do
so you have to come back I'm sorry!!